why do I pick on 8th Place trophies  because I know unlimited 25 year olds in  the world are anxious because they're  scared of losing because an entire  generation of parents demonized losing  when you should be making your kids lose  24 7 365. everyone's like social media's  got these kids [ __ ] up no no I love  when Boomers and older Millennials are  like [ __ ] these gen Z kids I'm like you  [ __ ] raise them [ __ ]  your kids sucked at soccer but you  wanted them to get a trophy but they  [ __ ] sucked at soccer so you didn't  want them to cry little tears when they  were little now they're crying big tears  when they're big kids are scared out  here because they think losing's bad you  want me to leave with something losing  is the [ __ ] best